joining us now is eliza collins
political uh reporter for the wall
street journal eliza
good afternoon thanks for being here so
what does this mean
for the confirmation process having the
president in the hospital
and what exactly happens next with all
this just weeks from election day
well it's a mess uh in terms of the
election it's absolutely not what the
trump campaign wants to be talking about
you know mick mulvaney talking about how
he needs to be out in public if he can
on the truman balcony
well the president is in the hospital
and the conversation right now
is about his health and the confusing
signals that
reporters are getting on just you know
the state of
his infection so that's what everyone is
talking about not the president being
out in front of a rally this is a
president
who has made his campaign about being in
front of people being in front of a lot
of people
interacting with crowds for a long time
the criticism was on joe biden for not
having campaign events
well now as hillary was talking about
earlier joe biden and kamala harris have
plans to be
out on the road whereas the president is
in the hospital
they did announce today that mike pence
will be out on the road next week so
there is
some movement from the trump campaign
but this is not where you want to be one
month before
election day it would be interesting to
see how much more we'll we'll see the
vice president out there
um campaigning as we get closer and as
the president does remain for
an unknown period of time in the
hospital you have these
this pair of events for the president
canceled in key states
florida and wisconsin of course so what
do you expect to see then as far as
changed strategy on the part of the
trump campaign so close to election day
well we saw the trump campaign canceling
events saying events
future events would be virtual they did
announce the vice president on
that one event i mean i think if there
are healthy surrogates they will be out
on the road
certainly it is definitely better to be
out in front
talking to voters but this is a campaign
that does has a have a
very strong digital presence they did
use that digital presence right after
you know the pandemic started and
everything was shut down in the
beginning before turning to the trail
so they can tap back into that you know
if the president is feeling well enough
he's done tele rallies in the past
they can go out he can do interviews so
they can do
all of those things but the key here is
that this president
has made a huge part of his campaign
being out
talking to people and really downplaying
the effects of coronavirus saying
that you know it was getting better the
economy was getting better people needed
to return to their normal lives and he's
unable to return to his normal life
right now
uh we hope the best we'll see what uh
the coming hours and days look like for
the president
meanwhile there's questions over what
this means for the confirmation process
obviously also crucial to the election
of amy coney barrett the new york times
this morning trump's diagnosis in
peril's quick supreme court
nomination timeline senator rick scott
doesn't think so you've
you mentioned the virtual nature of just
about everything these days he said
there's
no reason that we can't go forward with
this listen
so we've since march we've been hosting
our our
our hearings by uh by webex you can you
can either show up in person in social
distance which is what we do we're in
big rooms and we're not close to each
other
or you can do it by video so there's no
reason we can't continue to
to do that so i don't i don't think this
is going to upend anyway anything
senator senator mitch mcconnell said
today he plans to keep the senate out of
session due to health concerns
um but this can go forward so what does
happen next
final thoughts well at this moment you
said
the majority leader said that in person
voting is cancelled
but the hearing starting october 10th
will go forward or october 12th i'm
sorry
um at this moment they're going forward
but you know there could be
further positives coming up i mean this
is for the hearings this is not for
voting in person so
we just have so many unknowns at this
moment it's on
elizabeth eliza thank you from the wall
street journal for us this afternoon
thank you